Here we want to know the extent to which proximity can influence attraction,
that is how close someone is to us. It turns out that when selecting a
potential mate, we see that where someone lives can play a significant role in
who we select simply due to their proximity. Meaning that if you grow up in the
Midwest in the United States, this likely rules out the possibility of falling
in love with someone who lives in Paris. That is, unless you travel to Paris on
vacation, and meet the love a your life. Therefore, proximity to other
individuals provides us the opportunity for attraction. It may not come as a
surprise to you, but physical features can play a large role in attraction. For
example, men who are attracted to women tend to prefer the hourglass figure.
And some people believe that this figure is associated with fertility. On the
other hand, women who are attracted to men tend to prefer the tapering V body
figure. Some field studies have found that women's weight and men's height are
the best predictors to how many responses they'll get to a personal ad. Another
study that looked at online dating choices of men and women found that physical
attractiveness was the only predictor of dating choice. And as it turns out,
appearance, doesn't always always play a role in who we're attracted to. It
plays a role in many different contexts.